when solving physics problems we have
fundamental principles for instance we
have Newton's second law and we also
have an energy principle work
non-conservative equals the change in
kinetic energy plus the change in
potential energy and many times students
are challenged by do I use this law do I
use that law why do I use one or the
other do I use both at the same time can
I get the same answers etc now I want to
illustrate a particular category of
problems where we have some type of
circular motion and why we need to use
both of these laws so let's consider
let's go back to our dome example at MIT
and let's say we have an object that's
on the dome and now let's write out a
Freebody diagram for this object so we
have our gravitational force we have a
normal force and here let's just assume
that our dome is frictionless for
simplicity so what you see here and is
that the object is displacing in a
direction now here if I choose R hat and
theta hat and if I choose a coordinate
system where I take my positive angle
theta this way that the normal force and
the displacement are perpendicular now
what that means is that the work done by
the normal force F normal dot d s is
zero because while we're calling F
normal equal to the normal force and
that the normal force is perpendicular
to the displacement so what that means
is all information about the normal
force is not included in the energy
principle in fact the energy principle
is the work that's done is just the
amount this is angle theta so this is
angle theta
so the actual work done by the
gravitational force gene is the
component of G mg sine theta times the
displacement D s so the only work that's
appearing here and this is conservative
and so when we integrated this work and
got that the work done by the
gravitational force is minus the change
in potential energy that's showing up
here so the part of the force that's in
the direction of the motion is giving us
the energy condition but we're losing
all information about the forces in the
radial direction so we also because also
what we need is Newton's second law in
the direction perpendicular to the
displacement displacement is in the
theta hat direction so we need Newton's
second law in the radial direction and
that we have our hat is we have a normal
force minus mg cosine theta and the
object is undergoing circular motion so
it's equal to minus M V squared over R
where R is the radius of the dome this
equation is not an all included in the
energy condition you may say well what
about the tangential Newton's second law
which is mg sine theta equals M R d
squared theta DT squared but it's
precisely this equation that's
integrated
with respect to the displacement and
that gives us our energy principle so in
summary the energy principle is the
integration of Newton's second law in
the direction of motion and we're
completely missing the application of
Newton's second law in the direction
perpendicular to the motion energy does
not account for that and that's why we
needed separately to apply both of the
principles of energy and Newton's second
law in the radial direction in order to
figure out how to solve this problem now
this idea is true in general when you
have circular motion you need the energy
equation which is the tangentially
integrated in Newton's second law in the
tangential direction and you need
Newton's second law in the direction
perpendicular to that circular motion